(upbeat music)
Hi Rob, this is Tyler
calling from North Dakota,
I'm a big fan.
I love the podcast.
I just got done watching all the episodes
of "The Lowe Files"
with you and your boys.
And I got to say it was really fun
and it was great to watch.
I'm just curious.
Are there any topics or
anything else that you wish
that you guys had covered
on "The Lowe Files"
of you and your boys
before it went off the air?
Thank you very much,
and keep up the good work.
Hey, Howard.
Thank you.
First of all, thank you for
watching "The Lowe Files."
It was really a labor of love.
I mean, let's face it,
any dad who has the
opportunity to run around
in a souped up truck
with their boys solving
supernatural mysteries
is going to jump at the chance as I did.
Oh yeah.
There's so much more
stuff that I wanted to do.
We were going to go to Hawaii and
and do the Menehunes
and the Night Marchers.
So the Night Marchers
are spirits that march up
and down the Island of the big
Island with torches at night.
And if you look at them, they kill you.
And the Menehunes, are little tiny
like elves that run around and play tricks
on you and put your shoes in
the wrong room or steal things.
They're sort of like
mischievous little elves.
So that also, by the way
it would have been a great
excuse to go to Hawaii.
I mean, there was the,
the secret space force.
We did a little bit of that.
I'm fascinated.
I wanted to go to Mount
Shasta to look at the
the supposed giants that
live inside the mountains.
And apparently when certain
clouds come over Mount Shasta
which only happen on
Mount Shasta, apparently
that's when the space ship
is there loading people
in and out.
Oh yeah.
You heard me.
These are the things that supposedly go
on that may or may not
be complete bullshit
and "The Lowe Files"
was there to find out.
Maybe, I want to do more "Lowe Files."
Maybe one day we'll get to do it
but I love that you watched it.
And those would've been the
next things we would've done.